We're ready for you, Your Majesty.
Three, two, one.
We've moved now into the '60s,
away from the first two series,
which were very subdued.
And now, we're into colour.
Amy, the wardrobe designer, is brilliant.
It's a huge team effort.
The Queen has a different outfit
almost for every scene.
And they're all handmade.
They are all incredible.
By the end, we'll probably have made
about 70, 80 costumes for the Queen.
And we've done over 40 for Margaret.
We've done blouses, skirts,
coats, jackets,
a real cross section of outfits.
You can have a week or less
to turn around a costume
from start to finish.
And you could fit up to ten at a time.
So, it's quite concentrated.
We go through every scene
to decide the feel
of what the Queen might wear
for that scene.
Whether it's a state ball,
it's an audience with her prime minister.
That all has to be thought out.
And then we decide on the design
and what we're gonna have it made in.
We have a load of Queen fabrics
that we can just go to,
a load of Margaret fabrics.
It is that personal.
The Queen's fabrics
and Margaret's fabrics,
you could tell at a glance
who was who.
The Queen,
I just felt she seemed more settled.
So we've kept her pretty much
in a palette of sugared almond colours.
Margaret is slightly more darker.
Bruised, if you like, a bit like her.
Enough!
There's a construct to Margaret.
But it's a uniform, what she has to wear.
You know, she's a married woman,
but constantly looking up ways
in which she could express
her individualism.
This is unlike any TV show,
even any movie.
It's so richly detailed.
There's one Prince of Wales check suit
which I love
and is a kind of stroke of genius
from Amy, the costume designer.
I don't know how many people
will pick up on the fact
that it is the Prince of Wales check.
I do feel much more like Charles.
Am I listened to in this family?
Am I seen for who and what I am? No.
They're just so good at what they do.
It's been really lovely
for something that is as big as this
to still feel like it's a family.
For me to do it well, it takes
hundreds of people to do this job.
So, I hope people will see a thread
of our royal family
in this huge story.
We have all made sacrifices,
and suppressed who we are.
It is not a choice.
It is a duty.